hello
bots trolls and other assorted internet
creatures
it's dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for october 15th
2020 we are under three weeks away from
the big election
there's a lot to talk about hunter biden
censoring on the internet and kamala
harris how much more do you want from me
people
uh but before we get to any of that
i often tell you guys i am not a
journalist i'm just a guy
at a desk telling you what i think
sitting in my house
in my office and i'm talking to a camera
telling you what i think i'm not a
i'm not a journalist in that i'm not out
there on the ground collecting facts
one of the things that journalists
journalists have done to ruin journalism
is when they get something wrong or they
make a mistake they rarely
retract the mistake or what they usually
will do is when they
when they get the first story wrong
that'll get you know thousands and
thousands of retweets be amplified
everywhere get tons of
youtube views and everything else and
then when they put the retraction up
they'll do it like in the middle of the
night when no one sees it and like
you know three people retweet it i
actually made a factual
error last week you're not gonna believe
it i am not the perfect human being i
on a uh on a simple definition of
gaslighting
i was talking about gaslighting last
week which is an internet tactic
and basically what i said was something
to the effect of that gas lighting is
when you attack people online
so over the top they don't even really
know how to respond
that's actually not quite right and by
the way many of you
politely addressed it in the comments
section so i said to my guys we're going
to address it
now a few people did attack me ruben
doesn't know what he's talking about he
got the definition of gaslighting wrong
okay but but actually most people said
you know we like you dave
you drop the ball on this one a lot of
people send me links and the rest of it
so i do want to correct
what the definition of gaslighting is so
the actual definition
of gaslight is in reference to the 1944
movie aptly titled gaslight
which is to manipulate someone by
psychological means into questioning
their own sanity that is actually the
sort of
internet 2020 definition of
of gaslight when i was saying oh you
just keep saying things that are so over
the top it's like people don't know how
to respond that seems like an
offshoot i would say that's an offshoot
of gaslighting but
hey i'm not the perfect human being guys
and i just want you to know
that and uh that is the official
definition of gaslighting and by the way
this is what we see
constantly when people are just railed
and attacked by bots and trolls so that
they don't even know what's real anymore
right like
it's just sort of the the culture of the
internet
as it is but before we move on to the
rest of the stories today
uh i want to talk to you guys about the
second
thoughts board game the quick thinking
verse
fast talking party game second thoughts
is this year's new favorite party game
that is sure to be a hit
with your friends and family on your
next game night the play of the game
calls for each team to quickly create a
list of words
for their opponents to decipher leading
to hilarious puzzlement
and laughter simply put it's a classical
word game
with a unique twist that allows players
to personalize the content with their
voluminous sense of word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imagination each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high-speed
attempt to stump the other team both
teams create a list of five things using
the letters revealed from the color dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is exactly how much time
your opponents get to guess them
second thoughts the quick thinking
versus fast talking party game
get yours today at second
thoughtsthegame.com that's
secondboxthegame.com
or at your local target store and now
matt back to me doing the show
all right guys so our three stories
today
um i think they're gonna two of them are
going to be pretty obvious in that we
had to talk about them and they're sort
of linked together
and then we just got a bananas clip of
kamala
and rachel maddow the the big story
yesterday
was this new york post story that came
out that seems to reveal
some things about hunter biden that a
lot of people have kind of been talking
about
but seems to now have some evidence
actual evidence behind it and some
emails because of a
laptop that was owned by hunter biden
that he dropped off at a store
so we're gonna get to that now
ironically that story
because it's about hunter biden and and
joe biden and all that that's the type
of story that of course would have been
ignored by the mainstream media whether
whether
regardless of how important it is
because it's a sort of anti-biden story
and it
involves his son of course the
mainstream media would have ignored it
now
of course it goes without saying that if
it had been donald trump jr doing
something
using business relationships of his dad
even if his dad wasn't president at the
time of course
the media would be going crazy with it
um
but there is a reason that that this
story really caught on yesterday and
it's because of the second story that
we're going to cover today
which is that twitter started blocking
the links to the new york post story
and then what happened was several
high-level people
including the white house press
secretary they were actually locked
out of twitter because they tried to
post the story
you also couldn't even send the story in
a direct message that's that's the
private messaging
system that people who are following
each other on twitter have to
communicate with each other privately
and you couldn't even post it there so
ironically
as big tech and facebook did some
version of this too where they were
warning people
about the story uh as they tried to
censor a story what did they do well
they did the butterfly effect and the
butterfly effect of course
is when you're by drawing attention to
something
you're then amplifying the the attention
you're saying don't look there it makes
everyone look there
so then the story got bigger and bigger
and bigger and yesterday basically was
everybody talking
about hunter biden and then that sort of
shifted into a
something that obviously i've been
talking about for years which is the big
tech
censorship stuff i know a little bit
about that
and uh and i actually had an exchange
with the ceo of twitter jack yesterday
and i think he may end up regretting the
exchange i actually wasn't trying to get
him but we're going to show you the
little exchange we had
and then finally kamala harris was on
rachel maddow
and they just laughed
up a storm about that fly that was in
mike pence's hair during the debate
and i want to show it to you because it
is another one of these incidences where
it's like my god
my god that tall orange hair plugged man
is a million times more authentic than
you people and i don't know how that
is it's a strange science fiction story
that we're living in
so there you go okay before we do
anything else though
let's talk about buildbar
are you guys looking for a new protein
bar that tastes like a candy bar i've
got one right here by the way
and it's cookies and cream i did peanut
butter yesterday i'm on the cookies and
cream
today i've got just the bran for you
guys bill bars are super tasty and come
in 18
amazing flavors my personal favorite is
peanut butter as i said but i've got the
cookies and cream today and i do love
the cookies and cream
they're covered in 100 chocolate
including both nut
and nut free flavors and are soft and
easy to chew with halloween just around
the corner it's
easy to slip up which is why built bars
are the perfect alternative to candy for
the health conscious guy
and i like to think i'm a health
conscious guy i can actually lose or
maintain weight while indulging in a
delicious treat
bill bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein and high fiber
and in the peanut butter one that i
showed you guys yesterday it's 20 g's of
protein 170 calories 3 gs of sugar
3 net carbs go to billbar.com and use
promo code ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at builtbar.com good for bars built
go or build boost
and now back to me here we go uh
okay so hunter biden i'm going to tell
you the the key bullet points of this
story you know i think one of the
problems we have right now is that
because we're inundated with so much
information
that when you start hearing stories
whether it's a political story or
someone was shot by
uh the police or there are riots
whatever the story might be
there's so many conflicting versions of
the story and everyone gets so into the
weeds of the details that most people
tune out and and i don't blame you for
tuning out and sometimes i tune out too
it's like you got a life right you might
want to
do something you might want to have
dinner with your spouse
or get laid do people still do that
that's what they were doing back in my
day
or whatever it is you might want to do
so and then we're hit with so much
information where you have to know
every little detail of everything so i'm
going to try to give you the bare bones
on this hunter biden thing so that if
you get into a conversation
with someone about it you will be able
to talk about it functionally so here's
basically
what happened hunter biden dropped off a
computer at a repair shop
in joe biden's home state of delaware in
april of 2019
okay so this is about a year and a half
ago and that's according to the store's
owner
the customer who brought in the water
damage macbook pro
and we believe this to be hunter biden
never paid for the
service nor did he retrieve it or a hard
drive
where the contents of the laptop were
stored and
the store owner also says that he
repeatedly tried to contact the client
but before returning the gear the shop
owner says that he made a copy of the
hard drive
and later gave it to former mayor rudy
giuliani's lawyer robert costello so
that
that's kind of interesting that he he
called the guy who dropped it off many
times which we believe to be hunter
biden
and then he did return it it sounds like
but then
he also made a copy of it and gave it to
giuliani's lawyer so he must have seen
something on there that's what it sounds
like and then what we should
make note of here and this is the sort
of big part is that hunter biden
introduced his
then vice president father joe biden to
a top
executive at a ukrainian energy firm
less than a year before
joe biden pressured government officials
in ukraine into firing the prosecutor
who was investigating the company
according to emails that were obtained
by the new york post
and joe biden of course is claiming that
he quote never spoke to my son
about his overseas business dealings of
course hunter biden
was paid 50 000 a month by burisma which
is this ukrainian company even though
he had no expertise right he had no
expertise whatsoever
so they were obviously buying access to
his father that
like it just it's just obvious and of
course many of you i'm sure have seen
the video
where joe biden is bragging and laughing
about how he got the prosecutor fired
otherwise that we were going to hold
back all of this aid money
so this is a smoking gun and you know
you could look at this story and you can
go oh well this is just
sort of dirty politics and nepotism and
all that and by the way
it is dirty politics and nepotism and
all that it is this is sort of how
it all works uh i suppose at some level
this is exactly what trump was talking
about in 2016 about draining the swamp
that this stuff
shouldn't work this way um
now i'm not that's not me sitting here
saying he's never used
his influence to help his children
because he obviously has
but if he had done that as president
that's different than doing it as a
private businessman right like if you're
a
if you're a hotel uh magnet
and uh you know you give your son a job
or whatever it might be well that's your
choice to do it and then if your son's
not qualified it's not going to work
and if your son is qualified it is going
to work that's very different than if
you work in the government
and your son is getting jobs for insane
amounts of money
50 grand a month when he's not qualified
at all just so those people have access
to you as a representative of the us
government in this case as the vice
president so there is
stuff here now the bigger part of the
story
i think is sort of the second thing that
i want to talk about which is the
censorship around this now
we can debate all of the nitty gritty on
that
and and by the way i think it's
perfectly um legit
for people to say you know with all the
stuff that's going on in the world right
now with
with lockdowns and covid and the race
stuff and the protests
and all of that that this story
is just sort of you know three weeks
before the election like they're just
throwing the kitchen sink at everything
and it's a distraction and all that i
think that's a perfectly legit
way of looking at things so that that's
up for you to decide right like you
personally have to decide how important
this
this story is to you does it sound like
it's seriously crooked yeah
does it sound like this is sort of
politics 101 yeah
does it sound like there's a cover-up
yeah but the
bigger story is now this which is the
censorship stuff so
twitter decided that it would not
let people tweet out the link to new
york post new york post broke this story
and it would not let people tweet out
the link meaning put it in their
newsfeed nor
send it via private direct message
several people
including the white house press
secretary kaylee mcinanny
were locked out of their accounts i saw
that jack pasobic was locked out of his
account
a bunch of blue check people were locked
out of their account
for posting the story i didn't even try
to post it because my feeling was
if i get locked out too it's an endless
headache
the story had already risen enough that
it was like okay enough people are
screenshotting it that people
are now realizing there's a problem here
um
there was also a facebook communications
guy who tweeted out something to the
effect of
he's not gonna link to it on uh on
facebook or he's not gonna link to it
even on twitter um but that in effect he
was saying but will down regulate the
story
so all of the stuff that a bunch of us
conspiracy theorists have been talking
about on the internet for
years about how they deboost about how
they
shadow ban around how they reorganize
search results to make you think a
certain thing
it's all coming out to be true and of
course it's all coming out now right
before the election
and you know that is actually why
when when every four years they say oh
this is the most important election of
all time
this probably is at least within modern
times
uh because it's not just about the
battle between
let's say trump which represents some
piece of america that we can recognize
versus the far left progressives right
it's not just that it's also
how we're going to be able to get
information going forward like trump is
sort of the last stand against big
tech and now i saw a ton of
conservatives yesterday saying we have
to regulate them
and my feeling is maybe maybe you can
break them up i mean this is again where
i'm more of a libertarian so i would
always want the market to do something
by the way that's why i started
locals.com to give tools to creators
so you're not so reliant on big tech and
if you guys haven't checked it out check
out rubenreport.com or download our ios
app
or our google android app and you'll
always be able to
connect with me and i'll be always be
able to connect with you if i ever got
booted off these things and we've given
those same tools to any other creator
so i like the market but i know that the
market can't solve everything that's why
i've always said that's why i don't
consider myself a pure libertarian i got
into that a little bit last week
with joe jorgensen the libertarian
presidential candidate so i saw a lot of
conservatives saying okay regulate
regulate regulate and
and this is a this is a dangerous game
you just have to be aware of what the
game is
even though i understand the impulse
there because the thing is okay so let's
say you regulate let's say just
today right the the republican-led
senate and the president decide to
regulate big tech whatev whatever that
means right they're going to get
send government regulators in we're
going to look at the algorithms we're
going to uncover all this stuff
well okay that kind of sounds good for
the next three weeks but you do realize
there's an election and if trump loses
you've now given the power of regulating
big tech
over to the democrats and they may be
much less inclined to watch out for you
guys the conservatives
so that's an interesting just it's just
an interesting philosophical piece of
what
power does when you when you give power
to another entity you got to be pretty
wary
that that entity isn't going to use the
power against you so i don't like the
idea of regulation
if you were to tell me that somehow
these these companies had to be broken
up a little bit
something like that i could get on board
that and what i definitely can get on
board is
actually what trump did but it hasn't
been put into play yet
which is stripping some of their
protections so there's this section 230
of the communications act
which basically looks at these companies
either as
platforms or publishers and if you're a
platform
meaning facebook and twitter and youtube
argue that they're platforms meaning
people just put stuff up there and they
just get out of the way they're just a
platform
for people to put their ideas out there
well then they have certain legal
protections
but if they're a publisher meaning if
they're deciding
what views can and can't be on their
platform well then they don't have all
those protections so uh
so a publisher a publisher excuse me
would be more
like say what the daily wire is or what
the blaze is or what i do here right
like we're publishers and that
we're creating this piece of content as
opposed to a platform that just says
we're going to put up these things so
trump did
this executive action on 230 but i don't
know that it's been put into place yet
um so it's it's a it's a big mess all of
this but i want to show you an exchange
that i had with jack
on twitter so jack dorsey is the ceo of
twitter
and we had an exchange yesterday now it
started off where
he basically was telling people that
they dropped the ball
on what happened with this with this new
york post story so he sends out
this tweet about the new york post story
he said our communication around our
actions on the new york post article was
not great
and blocking url sharing via tweeter dm
with zero context as to why we're
blocking
unacceptable and then what he did there
was he linked to a twitter
safety thread where they explained their
theory a little bit more
i jumped in i actually didn't expect him
to respond
and i said do you shadowband based on
political beliefs
simple yes or no will do now jack
immediately responded
and said no now just to be clear what
shadow banning is when people say
shadow banning what they mean is that
when you sign up for twitter
you expect you're getting a feed in
chronological order that you
follow a certain set of people and if
they post something it's going to be in
your feed
shadow banning is not that you banned
those people from twitter
it's that sometimes their tweets just
won't show up in the feed now any of us
that are
in the game and i suspect many of you
are in the game meaning you tweet a lot
you talk to people online a lot all that
stuff
we know when sometimes things just
simply don't get seen and i have people
that say it to me all the time
and you guys messaging me about how
you're unsubscribed from my youtube
channel
and the rest of it okay so i said do you
shadow band based on political beliefs
simple yes or no or do
now jack immediately wrote back no
now that's pretty interesting so jack is
saying
we don't shadowband now i think if i
could have rewrote the tweet i would
have said
instead of do you shadowband meaning you
jack i probably should have
said does twitter shadowband because he
may just be playing some sort of
linguistic trick here
between you meaning jack or twitter as a
company
um also he's not under oath so he can
say i suppose whatever he wants to me
right this isn't as if congress asked
him to twitter shadowband and then and
then he lied
but what i the reason i'm not trying to
make this about me the reason i
think this is an interesting point is
that if you look at the image
that we show you where he says no
there's something known as the twitter
ratio and this is where you know if
if you do something that really catches
fire that has meaning on twitter
you you get ratioed in a positive way
meaning you'll have you know thousands
of retweets and probably even more likes
and and generally very few comments
because people will just re
retweet that's their way and like that's
their way of saying oh i
i like this this is funny this is
interesting this is insightful something
like that
when you see a tweet that has tons and
tons of replies that usually means you
got ratio to hell because because you
lied or you're you're being called out
on something
uh as of us taping this right now and
this is probably
significantly changed even uh just in
the last little bit
uh there were almost 5 000 comments
to jack basically virtually all of them
i mean i did a scan virtually all of
them saying we don't believe you you're
a liar
you guys obviously shadow band you're
playing with words and the rest of it
i don't know what the answer is i will
just say one other thing on this i'm not
trying to make this about jack dorsey
i'm truly not jack did agree to do this
show publicly and privately several
times and then
um his people just they just seemingly
wouldn't do it that was actually right
before he went on joe rogan and i think
that appearance was so terrible
probably for him and for twitter that
they just you know you just kicked the
can down the road
um anyway i mentioned all of this not to
get in the weeds again
on just like little twitter back and
forth and everything else
but the way the game is being played
right now it's like
we are about as i said under three weeks
away
from a massive election and it's not
just
that crazy stories are breaking and
again it's for you to judge how
important you think the hunter biden
story is
it's that the companies that control the
way
we can receive information and share
information
they've decided that they are the
arbiters of what can and can't be shared
you know the twitter support thread on
that that i just referenced that jack
retweeted
he talks about how certain they won't
share certain stories if they're
unauthorized and things like that and
it's like well you guys did share the
trump
uh tax story right which was leaked so
we know that there there's an asymmetry
here and i think what has happened is
the people
the people now right us you guys me
we've woken up enough that they're
really losing control of losing control
fast and they've got basically three
weeks to figure out how to
how to recalibrate so that biden becomes
president because this
this like the lockdowns and so many
other things in our society are purely
about trump it's a it's a weird it's
just a freaking weird
weird thing maybe we are in a simulation
who knows
but speaking of simulations let me show
you two humanoids
uh this is kamala harris vice
presidential candidate
she was on rachel maddow and just check
out these two
genuine humans but i just realized that
i would
kick myself if i didn't just ask you
before i let you go
if you noticed the fly on vice president
pence's head at the time during the
all right or if that was something that
only could we could see it at home could
you see it sitting next to him
did you have feelings about like did you
have
the instinct to
you know
i just you know i think that it's
important that we kind of um
find a way all of us to move on
and you know kind of fly away from this
subject on to something else
yeah senator harris you are very kind
and let's just spare a thought right now
for the people who have to write closed
captions
for this portion of the interview and
for those who have to transcribe it
because they're going to have no idea
how to convey what we just communicated
lord the theater the fake laughter
the the the staring at the camera the
inability to talk it's just
all gross how donald trump is more
authentic than these people i mean i've
been saying it literally for a year i've
been saying it
it started really with elizabeth warren
when she had that beer remember she's on
a webcam
i'mma get me a beer and it's like man
trump dancing the ymca like this is more
authentic than all of you guys it's just
it's just bananas anyway i just thought
that would be a funny way to
to end the show today uh hopefully you
will see this
unless we got shadow banned or deboosted
or something else
make sure you're subscribed guys and
click that notification bell so you
actually see our videos
and and perhaps more importantly if you
want to join us at reubenreport.com if
they ever
if they ever take dave out that's where
i'll be and you'd be able to get
notifications from me
and the rest of it thanks for watching
everybody the adventure continues